independent single males are direct they
rely on themselves elusive it's not
they're particularly secretive it's just
that they don't engage in binalities Off
the Grid because of their character
traits Sigma males are less likely to be
on the web thinkers because of their
depth they often reject much of what
society says and does the test
shallowness Sigma males the test
superficiality and shallowness
charismatic because of their elusiveness
quietness and Independence many people
find them quite charismatic sigmas are
silently confident and that has power
but they are dark horses and lack their
desire for social approval makes them
Stand Out dominance dominate differently
they get what they want without others
noticing brooding they are undoubtedly
quiet and rarely speak unnecessarily
their moods are often darker they use
critical thinking they recognize
critical thinking skills are crucial to
getting by in the world just like rules
where the rules are not transparent they
may choose to sidestep the constraints
Sigma is the test that when others try
to control them and why others often see
them as Rebels they have no plan signal
finds it hard to dedicate themselves to
one thing for any length of time sigmas
are not impressive material well while
the alpha may be striving for money
status to show off the power of the
sigma male is content with what he has